all right we are just what two days now
from celebrating 2022 and we will be
counting down right here on channel 8
with celebrations from all four time
zones yeah one of the many performers
set for that night country star scotty
mccreery our host michael yo and nicki
novak sat down with scotty to hear him
talk about his new year's plans
so you're an executive producer i want
to start with the executive producer
part yeah five more minutes you got uh
the movie that came out now tell us
about how how was that experience for
you it was so cool i mean you write
these songs and they're coming from the
heart but you're really just writing
songs to play the songs and
for you and the fans and all that you
never think anything else outside of
that's going to happen so when we got
the call they wanted to do a movie on
this and it was going to be hallmark and
then the christmas season and they own
the christmas season it's like oh man
that's that's awesome and they did such
a good job with it and tying in the
songs and i might have shed a little
tear or two while i was watching
it got me it got me are you i'm an
emotional guy or like a like a romantic
movie kind of guy like yeah you know
when you're a married man sometimes you
just gotta sit down and watch those
movies with your wife because i like
like watching what was one that you
didn't think you would love and then you
ended up loving because i mean uh i mean
all those like sparks movies like uh
walk to remember or uh
what was um
the notebook what what place is your
spot where you write do you have a spot
in the house where every time i go to
the spot i know i'ma get something yeah
i convinced her to to let me change one
of our guest bedrooms into a studio so
i've got my recording gear there my
piano my guitars and that's kind of
that's i basically made the whole album
in that room at least wrote it basically
in that room what is one message you
want to say to her on new year's eve
during this show new year's eve next
year's to be our best year yet baby i
tell you
you know it's it's every year is i'm i'm
the luckiest dude me and her met when we
were five years old in kindergarten
class and we grew up together our whole
way so um she's salt of the earth
awesome lady so i'm lugging it out so
what's your goal for 2022 and beyond
you know i just i'm always trying to
learn and just learn more about me as a
guy life in general artist country music
i want to write more songs in 2022 and
start to finish and just see what we
come up with you know even though we're
not making a full apple next year just
you know have fun with it so next year
let's just go into it with full heart
love your neighbors love your friends
and let's all
go in it together let's build each other
up and make 2022 the year that it's
moroccan